hi
my name is eric sachman and i'm the
associate director of applications
engineering here at broken lights
i'm going to talk to you today about how
our new optoplasma b
discovery workflow will accelerate lead
molecule discovery
against difficult targets
and i'll be making some forward-looking
statements in this presentation
even the best athletes in the world know
that they have to take multiple shots on
target
in order to hit the mark in hockey top
scorers may need to take over 100 shots
on goal
as a result these athletes aim to
generate high volumes
of high quality shots in an effort to
win every game
drug discovery also requires a large
number of shots on target
in order to yield an effect an effective
therapeutic molecule
by some estimates less than five percent
of drug discovery campaigns
successfully successfully yield a new
therapeutic
and unlike professional sports this
inefficiency is extremely problematic
because each campaign can take over a
decade and cost over a billion dollars
success rates for therapeutic antibody
discovery against difficult targets
has been especially poor since these
antibodies often
need to bind cryptic epitopes or trigger
complex molecular functions
to date only one out of an estimated 800
human gpcrs
has an approved antibody uh
antibody therapeutic
to close the gap drug discover drug
discovery developers
need to find ways to increase the
quantity quality and speed
of lead generation
berkelights's optoplasmb discovery
workflows can yield hits against
difficult membrane targets like
gpcrs genovec has successfully
discovered antibodies against
three transmembrane proteins that
exemplify the common problems with
difficult targets
small extracellular regions reducing the
number of possible sites to target
high sequence homology reducing the
chances of eliciting an immune response
and
by extension likely lower frequency of
antigen-specific b
cells and poor surface cell surface
expression
making a cell-based screening difficult
across all three targets they've found
approximately 10 times
more hits than the traditional
traditional hybridoma campaign
i'm going to describe to you how our
newest
optoplasma b discovery workflow expands
on these capabilities to accelerate
lead selection molecules excuse me
selection of lead molecules against
difficult targets
antibody discovery using the traditional
hybridoma approach requires
immortalization of b
cells by cell fusion followed by a
lengthy process of expansion
sub cloning and screening the
immortalization step
often results in the death of greater
than 90 of b-cells and therefore results
in a significant loss
of b-cell diversity
new single b-cell technologies seek to
access greater cell diversity by
bypassing the cell fusion
however many of these approaches provide
little or no functional information
this results in significant time labor
and expense for
sequencing cloning re-expression and
characterizing irrelevant antibodies
that do not bind the correct epitope or
fail to demonstrate the desired function
optoplasma b discovery 4.0 maximizes
diversity of antibodies through direct
functional profiling
of plasma b cells from immunized mice
the workflow enables users to recover
thousands of hits by screening broad b
cell diversity
down select lead candidates by
functional profiling
sequence and re-express over 1000
antibodies for
less than 100 per molecule all in a week
the workflow begins with the loading of
a plasma b cell sample
onto berkeley lights's beacon
optoflytics system
the beacon system fully automates cell
sample handling
screening cdna synthesis and sequence
recovery
a 96 well play containing a purified
plasma b cell sample
is inserted onto the beacon
the beacon system then automatically
loads the cell sample
onto optoselect chips
each optical select chip contains over
20 000 nanopens
each less than a nanoliter in volume
that's greater than 10 000 times
smaller than a well in an isix well
plate
plasma b cells are cloned into nanopens
using berkely's optoselect technology
in which cells are manipulated by light
as shown here the light based
manipulation can be selectively
performed on cells with markers for
viability or
other phenotypic information
tens of thousands of plasma b cells from
the target population can be cloned
across multiple chips in under four
hours
nanopins enable rapid precise and highly
sensitive assays
the small volumes enable secreted
antibody concentrations
to reach detectable levels in a matter
of minutes
in the assay depicted on this slide
secreted antibodies from the plasma b
cells
bind antigen-coated beads and are
detected by
binding of secondary antibody this
results
in a fluorescent halo above the pens
containing antigen-specific
plasma b cells this assay is performed
on tens of thousands of cells
simultaneously
the video on the slide depicts a single
field of view in which hundreds of cells
are
are screened to identify dozens of
targets
or excuse me dozens of hits
antibody specificity and cross
reactivity can be assessed by performing
multiple
assays either sequentially or in
parallel
in this figure we depict three assays
running in parallel
and simultaneously identifying that
there
are antibodies that are specific to
androgen y
antibodies that are cross reactive to
both androgen x and
antigen y as well as antibodies that are
specific to
uh not that are not specific to either
antigen
cell binding assays can be used to
enable down selection of leaked
candidates
against difficult membrane targets
in these assays beads are replaced with
cells that are over expressing the
target antigen on the cell surface
antibodies specific to the cell surface
target are
again selected based on the fluorescent
halos at the top of the pens
containing antigen specific plasma b
cells
following the single plasma b cell
cloning and assays to identify
the antigen specific antibodies optoseq
barcoded bcr is used to automate the
sequence recovery
mrna capture beads with dual genetic and
optical barcodes
are loaded into specific pens and plasma
b cells are lysed to capture the mrna
reverse transcription is then performed
on chip to generate the stable cdna
following the cdna synthesis the optical
barcodes for each bead
are read out by fluorescence imaging
the optical barcodes are stored in
software to subsequently link
each antibody sequence to its function
the barcode beads are then automatically
recovered in bulk
over a thousand hits can be recovered in
a single 96 well plate
and additional hits can be recovered in
multiple well plates if the user desires
using this technology we demonstrated
the recovery of nearly 12 000 hits
from two optoplasma b discovery
workflows performed in a week
from a single plasma b cell sample
using a combination of fragmentation
next gen sequencing
and bioinformatics analysis optoc
barcoded bcr enables rapid and accurate
sequencing
of the full length variable regions of
antibody genes
the ability to reconstruct full-length
antibody genes from short reads
enables high throughput sequencing of
over a thousand antibodies from a single
run
on a standard alumina sequencing
platform
as the graph on this slide shows over
500 paired
heavy and light chain antibody sequences
were recovered from a single 9612 plate
and performing a single mysq run
production of lead molecules for
downstream characterization
typically includes costly gene synthesis
and laborious bacterial cloning
opto bcr rapid re-expression
enables production of antibodies in just
one week
to confirm function in a play-based
assay
amplified cdna is cloned directly into
re-expression constructs
enabling expression of over 1000
antibodies
for rapid functional confirmation
in this graph greater than 80 percent of
the over 250 re-expressed antibodies
exhibited antigen specificity
in plate-based elisa assays
the new optoplasma b discovery workflow
advances from b
cells to lead molecules in just a week
the workflow enables recovery of
thousands of hits by screening broad
b-cell diversity
down selection of lead candidates by
functional profiling
sequencing and re-expression of over
1000 functionally characterized
antibodies
by increasing the quantity quality and
speed of generating shots on goal
berkelight's optoplasma b discovery
workflow
will enable drug developers to discover
lead candidates
against difficult targets
thank you and please reach out if you're
interested in learning more